PROFESSOR: Alright, lecture
12 is about tensegrities,
like this one which you saw.
And when they're rigid--
infinitesimal rigidity,
and carpenter's rule theorem,
all in one quick lecture.
So, just a couple questions
about tensegrities.
Well first is about
infinitesimal rigidity
in general.
This is sort of extra, bonus.
I talked about one reason why
this dot product condition
is the right thing, which
is based on projection.
But there are other
ways to think about it.
So let's say we
have an edge, vw--
actually I think I'll
draw it w on the left.
So here's vw.
We would think of
this point is being
c of w, that's
your configuration.
This point is c of e.
Then we were talking about
when, if you have a velocity
vector, d of w, and
a velocity vector--
Say something like
this, d of v, when
it preserves the length of
this bar to the first order.
And the condition we had was c
of v minus c of w dot product
with d of v minus
d of w equals 0.
So the question--
so the way we said
in class this works is if
you look at the projected
length of this vector
onto the segment,
that's essentially
how much shorter,
in this case it gets
shorter, in this case
this is how much
longer the segment
gets to the first order.
And that corresponds to d of v
dot product with this vector,
because this vector,
c of v minus c of w
is this direction here.
c of v minus c of w.
So if you take the dot
product with this vector,
you get that projected length.
You want those two dot
products to be equal.
And so you want the
difference to be 0.
That's one way to
think about it.
But, in fact, this quantity
also has an intuitive notion,
if you've done some
basic mechanics.
This is the relative motion
of v with respect to w.
So it's like-- well
imagine w is not moving.
To do that you just subtract
d of w from all motions.
Then w will remain stationary
to the first order,
so all first order motions.
So then what's the motion of v?
Well, it's going to be
d of v minus d of w,
because everything get's
subtracted by d of w.
So that it is-- minus d of
w corresponds to drawing
that vector in the
other direction,
and then adding that
to d of w corresponds
to this kind of picture.
This is minus d of w.
And so this vector is
d of v minus d of w.
That's the sum of
those two vectors.
And the claim is what we
want is for these two vectors
to be perpendicular
to each other.
The edge and the motion.
And this makes a lot of sense,
because we're imagining w
as not moving, so
it's just v moving.
And we want the motion of v
to be perpendicular locally,
to the segment, because that's
going to preserve the length.
So that's actually, I think,
an even more intuitive way
to see it.
And since this video,
this lecture video,
has been online for
two years, every year
so I get an email saying
hey, you asked what is d of w
minus d of w mean?
And, yes, I didn't
realize it at the time,
but it's just relative motion.
And so, yeah.
It's like if you're
moving along this circle,
centered at w, that's where you
want to be, either straight up
or straight down.
Clear?
Some bonus intuition.
It's a little harder to
see the other conditions
from this perspective, at
least I find it harder to see.
But I guess I shouldn't
claim that, or else I'm
going to get more
emails in the future.
Let's see, if you
want it to be--
what does the dot product being
greater or equal to 0 mean?
It probably means
that this angle
is obtuse, which means that
the lengths getting longer.
And less than or
equal to 0 means
that the angle is
getting non-obtuse.
And if the dot product rule
of the cosine of the angle,
you should be able
to figure that out.
But it's a little bit
less memorized in my head.
Whereas dot product
equals 0, everyone
remembers that's
being perpendicular.
So this was struts and cables.
Next question was, a
couple questions here.
One is how can you say the
tensegrity you showed is rigid?
Because you can flex it.
This doesn't look very
rigid, this guy here.
It looks quite flexible.
And then there was another
question, by someone else,
saying why did you use
springs to represent bars?
And these are sort
of the same question.
This is flexible because
the springs are flexible.
The idea with the
springs, I mean
I'm just guessing why this
model is made this way,
springs are nice because they do
have a natural resting length.
So in that sense, they
want to be a given length.
And if you pull on them they try
to restore the original length.
Also if you push on
them, you can do it,
but they try to restore
to there resting length.
And right now these guys are
all on their resting length.
And what's cool
about this is you
could kind of feel
the resistance.
I mean this is what happens in
any material, you pull on it,
it can maybe pull a
little bit, but it
gives a lot of force going
back to its original state.
These-- I don't know,
these cables, probably you
could stretch that material
and very tiny amount.
I could feel the force,
it's a little less visible.
Here you can actually
see the force
and, because it's
so much smaller,
it's easier to feel
what's going on in here.
I think that's the intuition.
You could, of course, construct
these with steel bars.
It's just then it
wouldn't move, it
would be a little less exciting.
So it's up to you, of course.
But this is just one way to
build models of tensegrities.
But it's also why
it's so flexible,
because these bars
are not super strong.
But what's kind of fun is you
feel the equilibrium stress
here, that things go back to
where they were originally.
They kind of hold
in position there,
because all the stresses
here balance out.
And one more kind of question is
about-- sculpture-- tensegrity
sculptures are cool so I
thought I'd show you a few more
examples.
The sort of-- the master
here is Kenneth Snelson.
I think he possibly
invented tensegrities.
And I showed one
example in lecture,
but these are many more.
He's been doing
it since the '60s.
Some of them are very big, I
have some measurements here.
This guy is 85 feet long and
rests on these three posts.
And it's a little hard
to see the cables here,
but it's all struts and cables.
So using these bars
to be-- actually
they might be bars
in this picture.
I think they might be rigid
even when they're struts.
And some more.
This is one of the
longest, at 72 feet.
And this is the
tallest, at 90 feet.
Pretty impressive.
This is a taller version of the
one that I showed last time,
or in lecture.
So I'm not sure how he designs
them, he's an artist by trade.
Whether he uses computational
tools, or gadgets,
or I'm not sure, it would
be interesting to talk
to him, actually.
But if you want to see more
examples of this sculpture,
this is just a piece of
it, go to his website.
On the design side, our
good friend, Tomohio Tachi,
who do the origami
Origamizer Bunny,
has also done a
tensegrity bunny.
And he didn't design this by
hand, as you might imagine.
He designed it with a new piece
of software that hasn't yet
been released, called
Freeform Tensegrity.
You start with a
polyhedron, and there's
a few different initial
constructions that kind of
set that thing up as
a kind of tensegrity.
And then it solves
to make it balance,
to have an equilibrium stress.
And on the right is the stress.
These are what a
structural engineer
would call force polygons.
It's essentially the-- it's
like if you take this graph
and you rotate-- this is all
in 3D, by the way, so a little
tricky.
That's rotating.
In this case he's
pulling on things,
trying to force vertices
to come together.
And the whole thing is updating.
And as long as this number
down here is close to 0,
here it's 10 to
the minus 20, it's
a pretty good
approximation of 0,
then this thing
is in equilibrium.
It's again, solving
all those constraints
like we have before.
So force polygons.
You take every edge, you
rotate it 90 degrees,
and then sort of con-- imagine
constructing a little polygon
around each face.
So you scale the edge
by the stress in there,
and those polygons should close
up to be 0, if, at the vertex,
you satisfy equilibrium.
And you can draw
all those polygons.
Those polygons can
be joined together
to make one kind of graph.
And if that graph
closes up, then you
have an equilibrium stress.
So it's kind of a
neat way to visualize
that the thing is rigid.
Or rather that it would hold all
of these edges at fixed length,
and you have to verify that
the bar structure is rigid,
but this is
presumably constructed
to have that property.
So hopefully this software
will be released at some point.
It definitely looks
like a cool way
to play around with
tensegrities and design things.
Question?
AUDIENCE: Is there
any way to see
what happens to the equilibrium
stresses [INAUDIBLE]?
Uh.
I see, yeah.
That's a good question.
So can you see what happens if
I-- like when that one, when
I tweak it and then wobbles.
Yeah.
It would be nice to see that
in simulation, definitely.
This software is based on
free form origami designer,
and that has the
two modes, right?
One where you can change
the crease pattern,
and one where it tries
to stay, keep it fixed.
So I'm not sure whether the
software has the same two
modes, but it certainly could,
that's definitely computable.
You could basically ignore
the concerns for awhile,
pull on something, then let go,
let it restore the constraints
without it changing
the tensegrity,
like it's doing here.
And you should see it wobble.
In fact, in that
case you'd probably
want to use a less
good numerical method.
Because you don't want it
to stabilize as quickly,
you'd like to see it
jiggle for a while.
So it should be doable.
Could be an interesting
project to extend the software,
if it hasn't been
implemented yet.
I could ask him.
I asked him last night, he say
that the plan is to release it
at some point, but not quite
ready for prime time yet.
Other questions about this?
So I think this would
be fun to play with.
If you want to build
some tensegrities
there's a couple descriptions
of how to do this out
of various, easy to find,
household objects like straws,
or with these wove rubber
bands, things like that.
So you can check
out-- George Hart
has two construction
web pages about them.
They're linked from this slide,
if you go to the lecture.
That was all I
had for questions.
Any more questions
about this lecture?
All perfectly clear?
We'll be seeing a lot more
stuff about locked linkages,
the carpenter's
rule part, which is
at the end of class in the
next two-three lectures.
AUDIENCE: Can you explain
how infinitesimal motions--
Well, in general,
a linear program
is something like--
you have a matrix
and you multiply it by a vector.
And then you have, let's say,
in our case we have greater than
or equal to 0.
So when I say 0 I mean 0 0 0.
The dual of a linear
program is what
you get by transposing
the matrix, basically.
So you get-- you
rotate it 90 degrees,
or actually flip around that
diagonal, so all the columns
become rows, rows
become columns.
So now you've got
some other thing here,
which is going to be this big.
It's probably going to be less
than or equal to something
that big.
So this is a
transpose, this is y,
and this is usually
called c, this is,
in general called little b.
And they are relations
between these two things,
is the short version.
But you can kind of
see-- so in principle,
if we take-- this
is, in our case,
this is basically
the rigidity matrix.
This is rigidity matrix
prime, in the lecture.
Because if we want to write
greater than or equal to 0,
struts are just fine.
Cables we negate
everything in the row.
Bars, where we have equality, we
need both the original version
and the negated
version of that row.
But if we just imagine
struts for the moment,
because I mean subsets
everything-- well,
can be simulated by struts
and negative struts, struts
and cables.
Then we had the
number of rows here,
this was essentially the
number of edges in our linkage.
And the number of columns
here was d times n,
this was the number
of degrees of freedom.
These are the coordinates
of all of our things.
And then x here was actually
our velocity vectors, and so on.
Well, actually, I should
probably write that.
So this, what we're calling
velocity vector's, d.
This is our-- It's
like conflict.
This is different d.
These are the d vectors,
the derivatives.
So, what would these things be?
Well the columns here
are going to be edges.
And the rows are going
to be coordinates.
And remember equilibrium
stress looks like this.
Basically for every
vertex we have
sum over all other
vertices, let's say
v w is an edge of, what
is it, stress of vw times
c of-- I forget whether c of
v minus c of w or the reverse,
equals 0.
So this should look good.
The number of these
constraints is-- well here
it says it's the
number of vertices.
But in fact, when you say equals
zero, this is a vector sum,
so this has d coordinates.
When you say that equals
0, that's d constraints.
So they're d times
n constraints.
And how many things are
involved in the constraints?
Well essentially the edges,
every edge has a term in here.
So that's kind of
why that looks right.
You have to go
through the algebra
and exactly what's written here,
to see that when you transpose
it, you do exactly
get this constraint.
And there's the issue
of equals 0, versus
greater than or equal to 0.
So that's a little
bit more subtle.
But that's the short version.
And you also have to check that
the-- when your strut or cable,
you get just a sign
constraint on this thing.
That's maybe a
little less obvious.
But at least a high
level, this looks right.
And the relations
about the primal
and the dual linear
program about--
So for example,
this linear program,
which is characterizing
all infinitesimal motions,
if you find an infinitesimal
motion, twice that vector
or the set of vectors is
also an infinitesimal motion.
So the solution space
to this linear program
is what's called a
convex polyhedral cone.
Meaning-- I mean this is sort
of the beginning of a cone,
but it goes off to infinity.
You could take any
motion you find
and scale it off to infinity.
You always include
the origin 0, 0, 0.
Because you can
always do no motion.
But any motion can be scaled up.
So if this thing has a solution
at all, other than the 0, 0, 0,
motion, it's an unbounded lp,
meaning you go off to infinity.
And when the primal
lp is unbounded
you know things about
the dual, which I forget.
But you cannot have one being
unbound and the other being
something else.
And so that guarantees that
there's an equilibrium stress.
That's roughly how it works.
Are there questions?